what is a violin plot a violin plot is a
method of plotting numeric data and can
be understood as a combination of a box
plot and a kernel density plot it
provides a visualization of data
distribution but how do we interpret a
violin plot kernel density estimation
this is the outer layer of the violin
plot and displays the density of the
data at different values the width of
the plot at different values indicates
the density of the data a wider section
suggests a higher density more data
points whereas a narrower section
indicates lower density fewer data
points the violin plot is typically
symmetrical meaning it mirrors the
density estimation on either side of its
axis Central box plot which is optional
inside the violin there's often a
miniature box plot which provides
additional details about the data's
distribution the central line in this
box plot represents the median of the
data while the edges of the Box
represent the interquartile range giving
insights into the data spread whiskers
like in a box plot whiskers indicating
variability outside the upper and lower
quartiles they can provide a visual cue
for identifying outliers comparisons one
of the strengths of a violin plot is its
ability to display distributions of
multiple categories side by side making
it easier to compare distributions
across different categories or groups
let's take a closer look at this example
let's say we want to analyze patient
recovery times in days after surgery
across various age groups here are our
data with the recovery time and the
three age groups young adults
middle-aged and seniors now we can
display the data in a violin plot let's
have a look at young adults the recovery
times range between 4 to 8 days with
higher concentration around 5 to 6 days
this indicates quicker recovery and is
visualized as a broad section in the
middle of the violin plot in the same
way we can interpret the results of
middle-aged and seniors if you like you
can create a violin plot for free online
using datat tab just go to data.net and
copy your own data into this table then
click on either descriptive or charts
further simply select your variables if
you now scroll down you will be
presented with many charts that could be
suitable for the data including the
violin plot but why use a violin plot
and not a box plot the main advantage of
a violin plot over a standard box plot
is that in addition to showing
statistics like the median and the
interqual range it also provides a
visual representation of the
distribution ution and density of the
data this can be particularly useful
when you want to understand the shape of
the data distribution thanks for
watching and I hope you enjoyed the
video